[Musique]
disons-le tout de suite notre invité à
un personnage qui lui colle à la peau
lorsque vous voyez son visage vous êtes
un certain nombre à la revoir sur TF1
dans les années 90 avec un uniforme de
gendarmes oui notre invité a incarné
pendant une douzaine d'années Isabelle
Florence cette femme d'honneur qui
réunissait chaque semaine entre 9 et 11
millions de téléspectateurs
imaginez-vous elle a parfois frôlé les
50% de part d'audience et alors que la
situation était plutôt confortable un
jour elle a dit stop elle a repris sa
liberté d'actrice d'artiste de femmes
entrepreneurs elle a un peu disparu de
vos écrans mais pour mieux vous
retrouver au théâtre et vous êtes
nombreux à l'avoir suivi sur les
planches et notamment dans Europeana une
brève histoire du XXe siècle son premier
selon scène qui retrace les grandes
étapes du 20e siècle dans les yeux d'une
femme apparemment ordinaire les guerres
mondiales mai 68 l'IVG la place des
religions tout y passe et tout
2023 ce qu'on a à supporter quand on
regarde les infos est aberrant c'est pas
normal qu'avec l'intelligence humaine et
la faculté que nous avons les livres que
nous avons lu
qu'on permette qu'il y ait une guerre à
deux heures de chez nous et qu'on ne
puisse pas l'arrêter à cause d'un seul
homme
on marche sur la tête mais si vous me
lancez là dessus on va être très très
mal parce que je suis très passéiste et
je sais que ça n'est pas une preuve de
d'intelligence mais je pense que
maintenant je le revendique c'est-à-dire
que autant quelquefois j'ai beaucoup
culpabilisé en disant mais viens avec
ton temps les le monde a changé ok mais
ce spectacle
j'ai besoin de de le faire pour parler
aux jeunes j'ai une fille de 29 ans qui
lit et je trouve que
cette génération qui lit
j'ai envie de la rencontrer à côté de
cette génération qui ne lit plus voilà
et je voudrais m'adresser à tous ces
jeunes qui ne lisent plus et leur
raconter ce siècle parce que ce siècle
il est allé à la vitesse de l'éclair
véritablement parlons de votre 20e
siècle à vous il a été marqué par le
rôle dont je parlais en introduction
celui qui vous poursuit un peu cette
femme d'honneur Isabelle Florent je sais
que vous assumez parfaitement ce rôle et
que vous en êtes très fier donc j'en
parle assez librement mais je voudrais
qu'on l'éclaire avec une autre lumière
et celle du 21e siècle justement on est
en 96 quand la série commence sur TF1 on
est très loin de Me Too très loin des
revendications féministes d'aujourd'hui
et pourtant je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
penser que mettre en premier rôle d'une
série en prime time sur la plus grande
chaîne d'Europe et qui refuser une femme
dans un métier d'homme il y avait quand
même quelque chose de je vais dire le
mot d'un peu révolutionnaire et de très
féministe de la part du producteur c'est
sa première et unique série télévisée
c'est quelqu'un qui venait de la
publicité qui s'appelle Christian Ferlay
qui nous a quitté depuis et qui avait
décidé
ce que cette ce serait une femme qui
aurait le rôle principal et qui aurait
une équipe d'homme à ses côtés alors
j'ai démarré adjudant-chef j'ai fini
lieutenant je ne suis pas passé
capitaine
mais ce qui est très intéressant c'est
très important et je le répète mais
c'est pas grave c'est que tous les
gendarmes qui nous entouraient à part
les quatre personnes qui étaient proches
de moi n'étaient pas des acteurs c'était
des militaires du coup ça donnait à Caro
du coup oui oui ça donne une crédibilité
en plus c'est le cirage gendarmerie qui
supervise les scénaristes c'était très
sérieux c'était c'était quelque chose de
voilà c'était respecté et respectable si
vous voulez donc on était dans dans une
autre en 97 lors de la cérémonie des
sets d'or les Français vous élisent
meilleur comédienne de Téléfilm ça m'a
donné envie de me pencher sur le
palmarès de l'époque la même année
Véronique Genest gagne le 7 d'or de la
meilleure comédienne dans un feuilleton
pour Julie Lescaut on retrouve aussi
Annie Duperey Mimie Mathy que des femmes
qui sont restés dans le cœur des
français jusqu'à aujourd'hui ça donne
l'impression que les années 90 ont quand
même fait la part belle aux femmes aux
comédiennes sans que ça passe par un
combat c'est une illusion de le penser
il y a quand même eu un combat ah oui
j'ai eu un combat pour moi alors je ne
connais pas la l'histoire des autres je
la connais pas je connais bien Annie
Duperey mais je moi j'en ai bavé si si
j'en ai bavé ça a été très compliqué
très long alors je vais je vais faire
court parce que ça pourrait très long
d'ailleurs je suis en train d'écrire mes
mémoires mais je vais faire cours c'est
qu'en fait je suis arrivé avec ce corps
je n'ai aucun problème à en parler des
typiquement des années 50 donc j'ai des
formes je les aime bien je les assume
tout va bien mais je suis arrivée la
mode c'était Miou-Miou et Sandrine
Bonnaire donc moi on me casse-tait et on
me disait toujours ou trop grosse et
trop grosse trop typé voilà donc je suis
d'origine antillaise et italienne et
j'ai la peau que j'ai et je ne suis pas
bronzée je suis comme ça toute l'année
voilà je tiens à préciser c'est très
important
je plaisante un peu mais ce qui a été
compliqué c'est d'arriver à pouvoir être
qui je suis et d'arriver à trouver les
rôles que j'avais envie de faire et ce
succès m'a permis de
d'avoir un petit peu plus confiance en
moi et c'est comme ça que j'ai réussi à
monter ma société de production mais
avant toutes ces idées que j'avais ça
bouillonnait ça a toujours bouillonné
j'osais pas y aller et pour vraiment
répondre à votre question sans vouloir
en rajouter les années 80 pour les
femmes qui voulaient être comédiennes
étaient absolument terrible c'est à dire
que on va dire que les hommes ne se
conduisaient pas extrêmement bien qu'il
fallait avoir vraiment du répondant et
vraiment une forte personnalité pour
tenir le coup vous avez été dans des
situations délicates dangereuses ou bien
sûr bien sûr
et quand vous voyez aujourd'hui alors le
combat de ces femmes et je pense par
exemple à dellenel qui quitte le cinéma
parce qu'elle considère que cinéma
cautionne justement un système sexiste
vous vous leur dites bravo à ces femmes
et vous leur dites on aurait dû faire la
même chose nous on a été peut-être un
peu trop commodente moi je vais très
très simple on ne pouvait pas c'était
absolument impossible ni de dialoguer ni
de discuter sinon de travailler pas je
suis pas la seule à l'avoir dit donc
c'est pas un scoop mais c'est notre
génération c'était comme ça la
Libération elle est elle est
extraordinaire cette parole qui circule
elle est capitale et je trouve ça
formidable je trouve aussi formidable
quelque chose de qui est pour moi a été
compliqué à comprendre et à gérer c'est
la l'indépendance et la force des jeunes
femmes aujourd'hui par rapport à leur
corps à cette liberté qu'elles ont de
s'assumer tel qu'elles sont de
s'habiller comme elles ont envie car
nous ne pouvions pas le faire
et donc ça ça m'impressionne beaucoup et
je trouve cette jeunesse forte
extrêmement forte extrêmement
indépendante et magnifique c'est
intéressant parce que ce qu'on remarque
quand même dans votre carrière c'est
votre soif d'indépendance à vous votre
soif de liberté votre besoin viscéral de
ne pas être enfermé dans un carcan c'est
ça qui vous fait quitter la série Une
femme d'honneur c'est aussi ça qui vous
fait refuser je crois un rôle dans un si
grand soleil qui est quand même une
série qui cartonne sur France
Télévisions
à chaque fois vous avez vous avez peur
d'être prisonnière d'étouffer alors
pour mieux comprendre mon mes réactions
il faut repartir un petit peu avant
parce que des séries j'en ai fait quatre
ou cinq avant la femme d'honneur mais on
ne me parle que de la et je comprends
bien sûr vu son succès et je l'aime mais
du coup ça faisait 30 ans déjà que je
j'avais des incarnais des héroïnes
récurrentes et
ce n'est pas la lassitude qui m'a fait
partir parce que je ne me suis j'adore
ce personnage c'est que j'avais envie de
proposer des choses et qu'on ne
m'écoutait pas donc j'arrivais avec des
idées de scénarie avec des histoires
j'en avais plein plein de tiroirs des
histoires et on me disait non à chaque
fois parce qu'on me disait reste où tu
es en fait tu es bien là oui et c'est
quoi bien là où je suis là où en tant
que femme ou en tant que comédien en
tant que comédienne en tant que
comédienne et du coup c'est vrai que
j'ai attendu j'ai attendu longtemps et
les trois dernières années voilà je la
coupe à la coupe a des bornes mais alors
quel est votre regard sur le succès par
exemple de HPI qui est une série qui bat
tous les records d'audience sur TF1
Audrey Floro qui incarne Morgane Alvaro
un rôle fort une actrice puissante qui
prend toute la lumière elle aussi en 25
ans on est passé de Isabelle Florent à
Morgane elle va dans un autre jour qui a
cartonné aussi on a capitaine Marleau
joué par Corinne Masiero pas du tout
diplomate
plutôt porté sur l'alcool vous y voyez
une évolution de des attentes du public
on aimait plutôt les personnages un peu
lisses un peu consensuel aujourd'hui on
aime les personnages cliquant oui je
pense que les gens avaient pas trop
envie d'être déstabilisés ou déranger on
a moi souvent j'ai entendu ça il faut
les rassurer il faut rassurer les gens
et
c'était une époque on avait très peu de
marge de manœuvre nous en tant que
comédienne par exemple mon personnage
n'a jamais eu d'aventure moi j'arrêtais
pas de dire je t'en supplie je voudrais
qu'elle se bourre la gueule au moins une
fois dans sa vie et si on allait danser
je les ai allez on va en discothèque
mais c'était pas possible voyez où on en
était donc vous auriez aimé incarner
mais je trouve que c'est un rôle
extraordinaire j'adorais ça c'est pour
ça que je fais du théâtre parce que sur
scène quand j'étais notamment avec
Christian Vadim au Théâtre des Variétés
j'ai j'ai tout explosé c'est à dire que
j'ai j'ai dézippé j'ai déconné j'ai fait
l'idiote la folle je danse je crie je
pleure je ris je suis comédienne moi je
il suffit qu'on me donne un canevas
c'est tout mais à l'époque c'était pas
possible on nous demandait toujours de
jouer la même chose et c'est aussi pour
ça que j'ai fait mes j'ai fait mes films
à moi et c'est pour ça que le premier
que j'ai fait écrit c'est un rôle de SDF
et demain Paula c'est un de mes plus
beaux téléphoniques c'était une femme
qui avait tout perdu qui était avocate
qui vivait dans la rue et
moi je me souviens très bien avoir porté
ce projet à TF1 et on m'a répondu ça ne
marchera jamais donc je suis allée à
France Télévisions je suis tombée sur
une femme exceptionnelle qui s'appelle
Laurence Bachman qui était donc
directrice des programmes de la fiction
à l'époque qui m'a dit oui mais elle a
même pas lu elle m'a dit oui
et on a fait 8 millions et demi
téléspectateurs
votre soif de liberté vous êtes donc
mené vers le théâtre vers le métier
d'entrepreneurs de spectacle depuis 15
ans vous êtes quasiment sur scène tous
les ans dans toute la France et vous y
tenez juste une embellie alors on s'aime
voyage en ascenseur un nouveau départ et
vous avez dit un jour le théâtre c'est
mon bonheur c'est cette liberté dont
vous parliez qui vous transporte c'est
ça que vous retrouvez dans le passé
alors la scène je
suis pas la seule tout le monde doit
vous dire la même chose mais c'est pas
grave sur scène je me sens en liberté je
suis libre il peut tout m'arriver
d'ailleurs il met tout arrivé puisque on
peut avoir un trou de mémoire on peut
être obligé
ça arrive à tous les acteurs qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on plonge on plonge on
improvise soit on improvise si c'est
possible là je vais être seul donc ça va
pas être possible
mais il y a des copains en face qui vous
tendez là vous faites qu'est-ce
ce que je réponds bon ça c'est
anecdotique parce que bon c'est ça peut
arriver tout le temps mais la liberté
c'est surtout la liberté j'ai
l'impression je dis toujours que quand
on travaille sur un spectacle on est
enfermé dans le noir pendant 2 mois je
dis souvent j'ai l'impression d'être un
sculpteur devant une mode de terre vous
savez ou de glaise ou de ce que vous
voulez et tous les jours en façonne en
façonne en façonne et ce qui me fascine
quand je vous parle de liberté c'est que
entre la première la première où on est
dans un état mais incroyable stress et
vraiment des très malheureux plutôt que
sauf à la fin une fois que c'est fini
mais tous les jours tous les jours le
spectacle est différent tous les jours
on progresse et on creuse et on creuse
et quand arrive la cinquantième même la
dixième ça y est on est heureux et on
est libre en liberté donc on peut tout
essayer il peut tout faire sur scène et
puis ce que je lisais c'est que vous
avez fait venir des gens au Théâtre des
gens qui n'allaient jamais au théâtre
mais parce qu'il vous suivait dans les
séries télé notamment dans une femme
c'est ma grande et c'est tous les jours
tous les jours il y a des gens qui
m'attendent pour me dire j'étais jamais
venu au théâtre de ma vie c'est la
première fois mais c'est mignon je
voulais vous voir en vrai je dise ça va
vous êtes pas trop
j'ai un document à vous proposer corinne
Touzet qui est délivrée par nos
partenaires les Archives nationales ne
sortait pas les lunettes je vais le
décrire ce document vous inquiétez pas
pour les gens qui nous écoutent et vous
allez comprendre vous pourquoi je vous
le propose le public peut être un peu
moins mais vous allez leur expliquer il
s'agit de l'annexe du passeport français
l'équivalent d'un visa d'un membre de la
famille Fratellini en l'occurrence Paolo
Fratellini sur lequel on peut lire qu'il
est autorisé à entrer sur le sol
français pour exercer son métier de
clown j'imagine que ça vous touche un
peu vous l'amoureuse du et de l'Italie
ah oui bravo parce qu'on étudier un
petit peu c'est un peu bossé alors oui
je suis clown de formation c'est mon mon
premier c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé
dans la rue même j'adore ça je c'est une
passion le cirque est une passion donc
j'y vais tout le temps je vais tout voir
je connais tous les clowns de France et
de Navarre et même de Suisse de Belgique
et d'Italie alors Fratellini oui bien
sûr
puisque j'ai j'ai
souvent été chez Annie Fratellini dans
son école et voir ses élèves qui
faisaient un travail merveilleux et
Pierre et texte donc
avec qui j'ai une ou deux fois pu
échanger qui était mon héros comme
Charlie Chaplin et alors oui l'Italie
parce que mon grand-père donc bon
arrière grand-père maternelle avait
passé la frontière un peu comme ça et
installé en France et ça plaît Béa KO
et oui c'est un pays où je suis tout le
temps où je vais tout le temps et je
pense que je finirai ma vie que j'aime
profondément le cirque arrive dans votre
vie à l'adolescent vous faites la
rencontre difkinio qui vous accueille
dans son école de cirque et qui vous
forme aux techniques de clown à ce
moment là vous trouvez aussi un peu une
famille un univers qui vous sort aussi
de la solitude de la petite fille unique
et un peu de ça alors il y a un effet
trop possible vous êtes une femme de
troupe finalement alors je pense que je
suis une femme de troupe profondément
mon rêve c'est d'avoir un petit lieu à
moi quelque part dans le trou du cul de
la France pardon excuse-moi
dans la vie et un petit lieu comme ça
200 places 150 places à mirait très bien
puis je cherchais une famille parce que
mes parents se séparent ça allait très
très mal à la maison et j'avais trouvé
voilà ce subterfuge pour pour m'absenter
refuge voilà voilà et c'est vrai qu'on
formait une troupe donc c'était et elle
a lueur de celle que vous êtes
aujourd'hui quel conseil donneriez-vous
à la petite fille qui se lance dans la
vie à la petite fille que vous étiez
avant qu'elle ne se lance vous lui
diriez elle voulait être vétérinaire la
petite fille donc
j'ai pas ma vie avec les animaux après
je voulais être interprète parce que
j'étais archi doué et je parlais les
trois langues couramment quand j'étais à
l'école je faisais tout seul et je lui
dirai arrête d'avoir peur parce que je
suis quelqu'un qui doute de tout tout le
temps et je trouve qu'un certain âge
c'est fatigant et en même temps Virginie
Lemoine me dit parce qu'elle est comme
moi elle me dit si on ne doutait pas on
ne serait pas là où on est aujourd'hui
et je crois qu'elle a raison et c'est
marrant j'allais venir parce que vous
étiez très mal dans votre peau quand
vous étiez enfant et ado et ça semble
toujours assez paradoxal alors que c'est
fréquent que des artistes disent qu'ils
sont très timides très mal dans leur
peau et pourtant il s'expose ils sont
complexés mais il s'exposent je sais
même pas si finalement il y a un
paradoxe est-ce qu'on vient chercher
l'amour dans le regard des autres il y a
quelque chose de cet ordre là la
confiance dans le regard des autres je
sais pas je pense que moi je pense que
j'ai pas mal brûlé c'est-à-dire que j'ai
cherché à me faire peur à me faire
violence je crois beaucoup
et il faut avouer que ce plaisir cette
immense bonheur que m'apportait le jeu
je ne l'ai trouvé nulle part ailleurs
donc quand j'ai démarré c'était au lycée
j'avais l'impression que c'était
possible et qu'il fallait que je
recommence pour voir si c'était vraiment
quelque chose de
que je savais faire et en fait je me
suis aperçue que oui je savais faire
mais cette
mon manque de confiance en moi faisait
que j'étais constamment en train de me
dire est-ce que je continue et il y a eu
une rencontre déterminante c'est c'est
Marion Sarraut parce que Marion Sarraut
quand je suis arrivée à Paris
1981 j'avais jamais vu une caméra
télévision de ma vie parce que je
voulais faire du cirque et du théâtre de
choses qui m'intéressait et il fallait
que je paye mon loyer donc j'ai passé
des auditions comme ça la SFP rue des
Alouettes et j'ai été prise et j'ai
appris mon métier sur le tas j'ai appris
mon métier avec trois caméras autour de
moi en permanence on a tourné à la façon
des Rois Maudits donc c'était mon
premier rôle j'étais vraiment pas
dégrosses du tout du tout du tout et je
n'ai aucun problème à en parler j'avais
21 ans et j'ai appris mais j'ai démarré
comme ça et là le le bonheur d'être sur
un plateau il était énorme et pourtant
vous n'aviez pas envie que votre fille
suivre le même chemin vous étiez très
soulagé quand elle vous a dit qu'elle ne
voulait pas être comédienne pareil vous
êtes maman
elle est donc styliste et ça vous a
beaucoup soulagé qu'elle ne choisit
pourquoi parce que c'est dangereux comme
métier parce qu'il faut avoir les nerfs
solides parce qu'il faut avoir la tête
sur les épaules parce qu'il faut avoir
une vie privée parce qu'il faut il faut
rentrer dans une maison où l'on se sente
bien et que c'est pas facile d'être
équilibré quand on fait ce métier et je
trouvais qu'à son âge mais heureusement
ça ne l'intéressait pas du tout mais à
son âge je trouvais ça j'avais peur
voilà j'avais peur pour elle en fait ça
voilà c'est ça c'est la maman qui a pris
le dessus sur la raison j'ai des photos
à vous proposer corinne Touzet ça fait
partie de nos rituels dans cette
émission
la première la voici c'est une photo qui
date de 1999 vous êtes avec le comédien
Yves Rénier la présidente de la Société
protectrice des animaux Jacqueline
faucher au refuge de Gennevilliers c'est
tout près de Paris c'était lors de la
11e journée mondiale des animaux et ce
sujet c'est vraiment votre combat vous
êtes une ardente défonceuse de la cause
animale on l'ignore un peu ça vous vient
d'où l'ignore pas trop
ça me vient de mon enfance mes parents
avaient des animaux je suis née dans une
maison il y avait trois chiens moi je
passe ma vie entre les chats les chiens
effectivement j'ai un peu tendance à
vouloir sauver le monde entier donc je
fais tout ce que je peux je passe tous
les coups de fil de la terre dès que il
y a une animalis il y a des animaux
meurtri des animaux qu'on frappe des
animaux qu'on jette par la fenêtre qu'on
jette des voitures aussi tout ça me rend
malade il sert et je me battrai jusqu'à
la fin de mes jours pour que vous aimez
c'est un combat alors dans un autre
registre une deuxième photo là on est en
2006 photos de 2006 lors du 59e Festival
de Cannes c'est votre montée des marches
c'était votre pour la projection du film
d'almodova projet
j'ai trouvé ça pas mal vous fondiez
parfaitement dans ce tableau c'est très
majestueux le cinéma vous en avez fait
un petit peu votre premier grand rôle
c'était la rumba de Roger Hanin 1987
pourquoi pas davantage est-ce que le
monde du cinéma est un peu fermé alors à
cette époque là le cinéma ne faisait pas
appel aux acteurs qui faisaient un peu
trop de télévision et moi je faisais
beaucoup de télévision et le cinéma ne
se montrait pas très intéressé ni
chaleureux à notre égard snobisme
pourquoi d'après vous faut leur demander
je m'en fiche complètement c'est dommage
parce qu'ils sont passés à côté de plein
d'acteurs merveilleux coréadoré faire ça
mais nous on n'a pas eu le droit
c'est intéressant parce qu'aujourd'hui
ils sont plutôt les acteurs de cinéma
qui vont vers la télévision vers les
séries tant mieux tant mieux il y a
plein d'acteurs de cinéma merveilleux
qui qui sont dans des séries qu'on adore
que ce soit sur des plateformes je peux
dire le nom mais à l'époque c'était pas
possible non c'était deux mondes
totalement fermés une dernière photo un
peu plus en forme de clin d'oeil
évidemment ce sont les trois projets de
nouvelles tenues dans la gendarmerie
j'allais dire j'ai pas celui-là on est
en pleine phase d'expérimentation de
sorte de polo et puis une chemise
laquelle vous choisissez
celui-là au milieu non je suis de gauche
à ma droite oui voilà qui oui c'est plus
c'est plus ouais pas toujours
confortable de jouer avec une tenue de
militaire j'imagine alors moi j'ai
triché vous savez non je savais pas
maintenant je sais pas alors les
matières n'étaient pas les matières
comment on dit réglementaire
réglementaire matière n'était pas
réglementaire et et les les matériaux
étaient raids et rêches ils le sont et
et
trop lourd à porter en tous les cas pour
quelqu'un qui est ce qui n'est pas le
cas des gendarmes entouré de différentes
projecteurs à l'époque il y avait pas de
l'aide donc c'était des projecteurs et à
chaque fois que j'avais des scènes
d'action il fallait que je passe un
treillis parce que je pouvais pas courir
avec et j'avais l'histoire c'est que
j'avais fait refaire la jupe de façon à
ce qu'elle soit un petit peu plus
féminine parce que la jupe des femmes
gendarmes elle est ouverte sur les côtés
à 4 endroits d'accord et moi je pouvais
pas courir avec la mienne et donc en
fait j'ai payé l'addition très cher
parce que à chaque fois il fallait qu'on
trouve un subterfuge pour que je puisse
passer un treillis pour pouvoir sauter
de l'hélicoptère au moment voilà
c'est du beau par contre les femmes
gendarmes que j'ai croisé apprécié
énormément mon uniforme oui une dernière
question qui est en lien avec notre lieu
corinne Touzet nous sommes entourés de
quatre statues qui représentent chacune
une vertu nous avons ici la sagesse ici
la prudence ici la justice et juste
derrière moi il y a l'éloquence est-ce
qu'il y a une de ses vertus qui vous
parle tout particulièrement
ouais c'est la justice parce que je
trouve qu'on vit dans un monde
extrêmement injuste pardonnez-moi de de
finir comme ça mais je c'est un monde
qui me qui me
dans lequel je suis en souffrance donc
j'essaye de trouver des subterfuges pour
arriver à le supporter et je trouve
qu'on est entouré d'injustice au
quotidien et de façon internationale on
va dire pour résumer et c'est important
d'en parler en début d'émission
effectivement c'est important merci
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
dans ce beau rendez-vous d'un monde un
regard merci de nous avoir fait partager
votre regard et votre monde merci et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis comme
chaque semaine à très bientôt sur public
c'est là merci
[Musique]